اطلعنا على ابرز التطورات في اراضي الضفه
خلال الساعات
الاخيره نعم قبل قليل في اخر التطورات دوت
صافرات الانذار في مدينه جنين بعد ما
اقتحمتها قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من
حاجز الجلمه وكذلك حاجز دوتان وتوجهت قوات
عسكريه اسرائيليه كبيره نحو قلب المدينه
ودخلت خاصه الى حي المراح وحي وادي عز
الدين القسام وهناك انتشرت اليات عسكريه
اسرائيليه
وداهمت عددا من المنازل وحاصرت ايضا
بنايات سكنيه وكذلك دارت اشتباكات في ال
تلك الاحياء بين مقاومين فلسطينيين وقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التي لا تزال حتى هذه
اللحظه تستدعي المزيده من التعزيزات
العسكريه باتجاه مدينه جنين اذا تشهد جنين
في هذه الاثناء وهي مدينه شمالي الضفه
الغربيه اشتباكات عنيفه بين قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي والمقاومين الفلسطينيين قوات
الاحتلال تزعم انها تبحث عن عدد ممن تقول
انهم مطلوبون لدى الاجهزه الاسرائيليه
ولذلك هي تحاصر في هذه الاثناء عددا من
البنايات السكنيه وكذلك تعرضت مدينه نابلس
شمالي الضفه الغربيه الى
عمليه اقتحام من قبل القوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وهذه القوات اقتحمت المدينه من
محاور عده وانتشرت في عدد من الاحياء داخل
مدينه نابلس وفي وقت سابق ايضا في قريه
الساويه في نابلس ايضا اقتحمت من قبل عدد
كبير من المستوطنين الاسرائيليين الذين
اعتدوا على المواطنين الفلسطينيين واحرقوا
هناك ايضا مركبه تابعه لاحد المواطنين
الفلسطينيين فيما ايضا تعرضت مدينه
قلقيليه وخاصه قريه باقه الحطب لعمليه
اقتحام واسعه من قبل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي التي انتشرت ايضا في عدد من
الاحياء بعدما اقتحمت هذه القريه من عده
محاوره ايضا وكذلك تعرضت بعض القرى في
مناطق جنوبيه الضفه الغربيه في مدينه بيت
لحم وفي مدينه الخليل ايضا ومن ضمنها دوره
الى اقتحام اسرائيلي هذا مساء ولا تزال
الاقتحامات الاسرائيليه مستمره في عدد من
قرى ومدن الضفه الغربيه في هذه الاثناء
كما قلنا وخاصه في مدينه جنين التي يبدو
انها تشهد عمليه اقتحام واسعه من قبل جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي و
ولعل حده الاشتباكات اخذه بالتزايد وسط
السماع اطلاق النار من قلب الاحياء
الداخليه كما قلنا وخاصه في احياء المراح
ووادي عز الدين القسام في داخل
هذه المدينه وهذه الاقتحامات تاتي
استمرارا للاقتحامات الاسرائيليه المستمره
بشكل متصاعد منذ السابع من اكتوبر وحتى
هذا اليوم في كافه مدن الضفه الغربيه
وقراها ومخيماتها وتن وتنشر قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عددا من الحواجز العسكريه بين
المدن الفلسطينيه ما ما يؤدي الى عرقله
حياه المواطنين الفلسطينيين في الضفه
الغربيه بشكل عام وتعطيل حياتهم اليوميه و
و اضافه الى استمرار عمليات الاعتقال
الاسرائيليه اليوميه في الضفه الغربيه وهي
التي جاوزت 6000 عمليه اعتقال منذ السابع
من اكتوبر وحتى هذا اليوم في ارقام قياسيه
حقيقه اذا ما قرنت في عدد الايام والاشهر
الماضيه وا يعني كما اشرنا قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ايضا ايه اقتحمت مدينه نابلس
وكذلك قلقيليه وبيت لحم ومدينه الخليل
خلال الساعات الماضيه